well something that will also be  affordable and shoppable is a pick from  drew's little yellow book it's my  curated list of stuff we update every  week on our website we freshen it up and  so today it's called  dish story and you save all of your  favorite recipes but it has family  history this high-tech recipe book  actually includes audio recordings so  you can record your mom or your brother  or your loved one in their own voice  sharing that secret ingredient to the  magical meatloaf  so everyone in our audience is going to  get a free one-year subscription to dish  story so please download it and enjoy it  on us everybody yay  and hopefully fill it with your family  members or your best friends or your  kids and your loved ones